In the last quiz I asked you to
modify a bunch of things in your app.
You may not have understood what
you were doing, but that's okay.
We're going to talk about it now.
Specifically, we're going to talk
about resources in your app.
Resources live under the res
directory of your app.
Res is short for resources.
On the other hand,
java files live in the java folder.
And we have MainActivity.java
located inside this folder.
An Android app is mainly made
of resources and java code.
The java code consists of
files like MainActivity.java.
Altogether it handles what should
happen when the app is running
like responding to button clicks or
other events.
Then you have resources that live
in the res directory of your app.
This includes images, text strings,
colors, dimensions, like for
width and height,
xml files like for menus and
layouts, as well as raw media
files like for audio or video.
One of the major advantages to
separating out the java code and
the resources is that we can
provide alternative resources
to make the app look
better on certain devices.
So if we want a different layout
on larger screen devices,
we can provide that by
just swapping it out.
Or, if we want to translate these
strings into another language,
then it makes it easier to swap out the
strings in just the centralized location
instead of having it scattered
all over the code files.